this time of year absolutely phenomenal
words wonderful berries it's thickened
with natural green ogre and then finish
with the most amazing champagne milk
this is a little bit of magic the fresh
vanilla seed slam it down all the way
open it up scrape out the seeds in
whisking the vanilla mint gives a really
nice sort of fresh and even more
fragrant perfume to the meringue bring
the up to the ball the meringue three
egg whites make sure there's no yolk in
the egg white whatsoever and whip up
your egg white lemon squeeze the lemon
juice in sugar whack it up full blast
look these wonderful nice rich meringue
moves come with the ball get your spoon
in the egg white and then with another
spoon for now then into the milk on your
spoon the milk over the meringue it
stops them from sticking together and
just leave them poaching there on the
side for about four or five minutes
the most exciting thing about making
this soup it's like the ultimate
smoothie blackberries blueberries
raspberries red currants
and the secrets allow the fruit to go
overripe so the flavor is extraordinary
mint yogurt cream
and this is where it starts to get
really exciting champagne off 300
million okay now it's [ __ ] everywhere
Ready Steady [ __ ]
who was that don't use champagne
sparkling wine two tablespoons of sugar
and that gets rid of that sort of very
strong acidity flavor lid on blades
pour into your bowl beautiful color
carefully lift out your meringue and
just sit on top of the soup and their
summer berry and champagne soup with
floating islands done in [ __ ] me it
smells delicious
if you have fruit that's not perfectly
ripe the tip is to put a banana in a
paper bag then add your unripe fruit put
it in a dark place and the banana